Hi, good morning Hank, it's, uh,
Friday? I think? Uh, today I'm not going to do a real video.
I'm going to do a live show video, but Nerdfighters, before you start to punish me, I have permission from Hank to do this.
It's going to save me a lot of time not to have to edit a video today, and I appreciate your patience,
But I am going to read to you the first chapter of "The Fault In Our Stars" today,
Which is something I wanted to...I've wanted to do for a long time, but, um,
and I tried to do once, like a few months ago,
But then I had to change a bunch...I wanted to change a bunch of stuff, so I ended up deleting that live show
But this live show is here to stay. I'm sorry that it's going to be longer than 4 minutes
But you know it's a long book um
And I'm gonna start reading to you now unless there's anything that I forgot to say um
Yeah, oh, I guess just the only other thing is that for those of you
Who are watching live can you please explain to people who are coming into the room for the first time?
that they haven't missed the entire thing because it's going to be recorded and they can go back and listen to the first chapter at
their leisure, you know they can listen to it a hundred times if they want, it's a little weird, but you can do that.
So this book is called "The Fault in our Stars", and it is dedicated to my friend Esther Earl.
And then after the dedication comes the uh...
You know how like pretentious novels always start with you know pretentious quotations from pretentious novels?
This book is no exception. It starts with an epigraph: "As the tide washed in, the dutch tulip man faced the ocean.
Conjoiner, rejoinder, poisoner, concealer, revelator. 'Look at it,'
He said, 'rising up and rising down, taking everything with it.'
'What's that?' Anna asked. 'Water,' the Dutchman said. 'Well, and time.'"
- Peter Van Houten,
An Imperial Affliction
Then there's an author's note. Which I will read to you now.
Author's note: This is not so much an author's note as an author's reminder of what was printed in small type a few pages ago.
This book is a work of fiction. I made it up.
Neither novels nor their readers benefit from attempts to divine whether any facts hide inside of a story.
Such efforts attack the very idea that made-up stories can matter, which is sort of the foundational assumption of our species.
I appreciate your cooperation in this matter.
And now begins the actual book:
The Fault in Our Stars
I'm reading from a page proof by the way, so there may be some mistakes.
But hopefully not if there are I'm going to have to stop reading and correct myself.
Chapter One:
Late in the winter of my sixteenth year, my mother decided
I was depressed,
presumably because I rarely left the house, spent quite a lot of time in bed, read the same book over and over, ate
infrequently, and devoted quite a bit of my abundant free time to thinking about death.
Whenever you read a cancer booklet or website or whatever, they always list depression among the side effects of cancer
But in fact, depression is not a side effect of cancer. Depression is a side effect of dying.
(Cancer is also a side effect of dying. Almost everything is, really.)
But my mom believed I required treatment, so she took me to see my Regular Doctor Jim, who agreed that I was veritably
swimming in a paralyzing and totally clinical depression, and that therefore my meds should be adjusted and also
I should attend a weekly support group.
This support group featured a rotating cast of characters in various states of tumor-driven unwellness.
Why did the cast rotate? A side effect of dying.
The support group, of course, was depressing as hell.
It meant every Wednesday in the basement of a stone-walled Episcopal church shaped like a cross.
We all sat right in the middle of the cross, where the two boards would have met, where the heart of Jesus would have been.
I noticed this because Patrick, the support group leader and only person over 18 in the room, talked about the heart of Jesus
every freaking meeting, all about how we, as young cancer survivors were sitting right in Christ's very sacred heart and
whatever.
So here's how it went in God's heart: the six or seven or ten of us walked or wheeled in,
grazed at a decrepit selection of cookies and lemonade,
sat down in the Circle of Trust, and listened to Patrick recount for the thousandth time his
depressingly miserable life story - how he had cancer in his balls and they thought he was going to die
but then he didn't die and now here he is, a full-grown adult in a church basement in the
137th Nicest City in America, divorced, addicted to video games,
mostly friendless, eking out a meager living by exploiting his cancer-tastic past,
slowly working his way toward a master's degree that will not improve his career prospects, waiting, as we all do, for the sword of Damocles
to give him the relief that he escaped lo those many years ago when cancer took both of his nuts but spared
what only the most generous soul would call his life. And you too might be so lucky!
Then we introduced ourselves: Name. age.
Diagnosis. And how we're doing today. I'm Hazel, I'd say when they'd get to me.
Sixteen. Thyroid originally but with an impressive
and long-settled colony in my lungs.
And I'm doing okay. —By the way,
I should mention that the narrator of this novel is a girl named Hazel Grace Lancaster
And she's 16 and as you may have noticed I'm a 34 year old man. That's a little bit awkward,
I know, like having a 34 year old man read to you in the voice of a 16 year old girl, so just
get over it. Just let me read you the story.
Sorry, I'm not going to say [extra gruffly] "and then I took off my bra" or anything, at least in this chapter.
um...All right
Once we got around the circle, Patrick always asked if anyone wanted to share. And then began the circle jerk of support:
everyone talking about fighting and battling and winning and shrinking and scanning.
To be fair to Patrick, he let us talk about dying too.
But most of them weren't dying. Most would live into adulthood as Patrick had,
(Which meant there was quite a lot of competitiveness about it, with everybody wanting to beat not only cancer itself,
but also the other people in the room. Like, I realize that this is irrational,
but when they tell you that you have, say, a 20% chance of living five years the math kicks in and you figure
that's one in five... so you look around and think, as any healthy person would: I gotta outlast at last four of these bastards.)
The only redeeming facet of support group was this kid named Isaac a long faced skinny guy with straight blond hair swept over one eye.
His eyes were the problem.
He had some fantastically improbable eye cancer. One eye had been cut out when he was a kid, and now he wore the kind of thick
glasses that made both of his eyes (the real one and the glass one) preternaturally huge,
like his whole head was basically just this fake eye and this real eye staring at you
from what I could gather on the rare occasions when Isaac shared with the group a
recurrence had placed his remaining eye in some mortal peril.
Isaac and I communicated almost exclusively through sighs. Each time someone discussed
Anti-cancer diets or snorting up ground Shark-fin or whatever, he'd glanced over at me and sigh ever so slightly.
I'd shake my head microscopically and exhale in response.
So support group blew, and after a few weeks,
I grew to be rather kicking and screaming about the whole affair. In fact, on the Wednesday
I made the acquaintance of Augustus Waters,
I tried my level best to get out of support group while sitting on the couch with my mom in the
third leg of a 12-hour marathon of the previous season's America's Next Top Model, which admittedly I had already seen, but still.
Me: "I refused to attend support group."
Mom: "You know one of the symptoms of depression is disinterest in activities."
Me: "Please just let me watch America's Next Top Model. It's an activity."
Mom: "Television is a passivity."
Me: "Ugh mom, please."
Mom: "Hazel you're a teenager. You're not a little kid anymore. You need to make friends, get out of the house, live your life."
Me: "If you want me to be a teenager, don't send me to support group.
Buy me a fake ID so I can go to clubs and drink vodka and take pot."
Mom: "You don't take pot for starters."
Me: "See, that's the kind of thing I would know if you got me a fake ID."
Mom: "You're going to support group."
Me: "Uggggggh."
Mom: "Hazel, you deserve a life."
That shut me up, although I failed to see how attendance at support group met the definition of life. Still, I agreed to go -- after
negotiating the right to record the one point five episodes of America's Next Top Model I'd be missing.
I went to support group for the same reason that I'd once allowed nurses with a mere 18 months of graduate education
to poison me with exotically named chemicals:
I wanted to make my parents happy.
There is only one thing in this world shittier than biting it from cancer when you're 16,
And that one thing is having a kid who bites it from cancer.
Mom pulled into the circular driveway behind the church at 4:56.
I pretended to fiddle with my oxygen tank for a second just to kill time.
"You want me to carry it for you?" "No, it's fine." I said.
The cylindrical green tank only weighed a few pounds,
and I had this little steel cart to wheel it around behind me.
It delivered two liters of oxygen to me each minute through a canela,
a transparent tube that split just beneath my neck wrapped behind my ears and then reunited in my nostrils.
The contraption was necessary because my lungs sucked at being lungs. "I love you," she said as I got out. "You too, mom,
see you at six." "Make friends!" She said through the rolled down window as I walked away.
I didn't want to take the elevator, because taking the elevator is a Last Days kind of activity at support group
so I took the stairs. I grabbed a cookie and poured some lemonade into a Dixie cup and then turned around.
A boy was staring at me. I was quite sure I'd never seen him before.
Long and leanly muscular, he dwarfed the molded plastic elementary school chair he was sitting in.
Mahogany hair, straight and short. He looked my age,
maybe a year older,
and he sat with his tailbone against the edge of the chair, his posture aggressively poor,
one hand half in a pocket of dark jeans. I looked away, suddenly conscious of my myriad insufficiencies.
I was wearing old jeans which had once been tight
but now sagged in weird places and a yellow t-shirt advertising a band I didn't even like anymore. Also my hair:
I had this pageboy haircut, and I hadn't even bothered to like brush it.
Furthermore, I had ridiculously fat chipmunk cheeks, a side affect of treatment.
I looked like a normally proportioned person with a balloon for a head that wasn't even to mention the cankle situation and yet--
I cut a glance to him and his eyes were still on me. It occurred to me why they call it eye contact.
I walked into the circle and sat down next to Isaac, two seats away from the boy. I glanced again.
He was still watching me. Look let me just say it, he was hot.
A nonhot boy stares at you relentlessly
and it is at best, awkward and at worst, a form of assault. But a hot boy... well.
I pulled out my phone and clicked it. So it would display the time:
4:59
The circle filled in with the unlucky twelve to eighteens, and then Patrick started us out with the serenity prayer. "God
grant me the serenity to accept the things I cannot change
the courage to change the things I can, and the wisdom to know the difference."
The guy was still staring at me. I felt rather blushy.
Finally I decided that the proper strategy was to stare back.
Boys do not have a monopoly on the staring business, after all.
So I looked him over as Patrick acknowledged for the thousandth time his ball-lessness etc., and soon
It was a staring contest. After a while the voice smiled
And then finally his blue eyes glanced away when he looked back at me, I flicked my eyebrows up to say "I win."
He shrugged.
Patrick continued, and then finally it was time for the introductions. "Isaac perhaps, you'd like to go first today
I know you're facing a challenging week."
"Yeah", Isaac said, "I'm Isaac,
I'm 17 and it's looking like I have to get surgery in a couple weeks, after which I'll be blind,
Not to complain or anything because I know a lot of us have it worse, but yeah,
I mean, being blind does sort of suck. My girlfriend helps, though. And friends like Augustus."
He nodded toward the boy, who now had a name.
"So yeah," Isaac continued. He was looking at his hands which he folded into each other like the top of a teepee.
"There's nothing you can do about it."
"We're here for you Isaac," Patrick said. "Let Isaac hear it guys."
And then we all, in a monotone said, "we're here for you Isaac."
Michael was next.
He was 12. He had leukemia. He'd always had leukemia. He was okay, or so he said. He'd taken the elevator.
Lida was 16 and plenty pretty enough to be the object of the hot boy's eye.
She was a regular in a long remission from appendiceal cancer. Which I hadn't previously known existed,
She said - as she had every other time I'd attended support group - that she felt strong.
Which felt like bragging to me as the oxygen drizzling nubs tickled my nostrils. There were five others before they got to him.
He smiled a little when his turn came, his voice was low, smoky, and dead sexy.
"My name is Augustus Waters," he said. "I'm 17.
I had just a little touch of osteosarcoma about a year and a half ago
But I'm just here today at Isaac's request." "And how are you feeling?" asked Patrick. " Oh, I'm grand."
Augustus waters smiled with a corner of his mouth. "I'm on a roller coaster that only goes up, friend."
When it was my turn, I said, "My name's Hazel. I'm 16.
Thyroid with mets in my lungs. I'm okay."
The hour proceeded apace: Fights were recounted, battles won amid wars sure to be lost;
hope was clung to; families were both celebrated and denounced; it was agreed that friends just didn't get it;
Tears were shed; comfort proffered. Neither, Augustus Waters nor I spoke again until Patrick said,
"Augustus, perhaps you'd like to share your fears with the group."
"My fears?" "Yes."  "I fear oblivion," he said, without a moment's pause."I fear it like the proverbial blind man
who's afraid of the dark." "Too soon," Isaac said, cracking a smile.
"Oh was that insensitive?" Augustus asked, "I'm sorry, I can be really blind to other people's feelings."
Isaac was laughing, but Patrick raised a chastening finger and said "Augustus, please. Let's return to you and your struggles.
You said you fear oblivion?"  "I did," Augustus answered.
Patrick seemed lost.
"Would, uh, would anyone like to speak to that?"
I hadn't been in proper school in three years, my parents were my two best friends. My third best friend was an author who did not know I existed.
I was a fairly shy person, not the hand-raising type and yet, just this once, I decided to speak.
I half raised my hand and Patrick, his delight evident, immediately said,
"Hazel!"
I was, I'm sure he assumed, opening up, becoming part of the group.
I looked over at Augustus Waters, who looked back at me. You could almost see through his eyes, they were so blue.
"There will come a time," I said, "When all of us are dead.
All of us. There will come a time when there are no human beings
remaining to remember that anyone ever existed or that our species ever did anything.
There will be no one left to remember
Aristotle or Cleopatra, let alone you.
Everything that we did and built and wrote and thought and discovered will be forgotten and all of this" -- I gestured encompassingly --
"will have been for naught. Maybe that time is coming soon, and maybe it's millions of years away.
But even if we survive the collapse of our sun,
We will not survive forever. There was time before organisms experienced consciousness,
and there will be time after. And if the inevitability of human oblivion worries you, I encourage you to ignore it.
God knows that's what everyone else does."
I'd learned this from my aforementioned third best friend,
Peter van Houten, the reclusive author of the novel 'An Imperial Affliction',
the book that was as close a thing as I had to a Bible.
Peter van Houten was the only person I'd ever come across who seemed to
(A) Understand what it's like to be dying and (B) not have died.
After I finished there was quite a long period of silence
as I watched a smile spread all the way across Augustus's face -
not the crooked little smile of the boy trying to be sexy while he stared at me,
but his real smile, too big for his face.
"Goddamn," Augustus said quietly,  "Aren't you something else?"
Neither of us said anything for the rest of support group
At the end we all had to hold hands and Patrick led us in a prayer.
"Lord Jesus Christ, we are gathered here in Your heart, literally in Your heart,
as Cancer Survivors. You and You alone know us as we know ourselves.
Guide us to life and the light through our times of trial.
We pray for Isaac's eyes, for Michael's and Jamie's blood, for Augustus's bones,
for Hazel's lungs, for James's throat.
We pray that You might heal us and that we might feel Your love, and Your peace, which passes all understanding.
And we remember in our hearts those whom we knew and loved who have gone home to You:
Maria and Kade and Joseph and Haley and Abigail and Angelina and Taylor and Gabriel..."
It was a long list. The world contains a lot of dead people, and
while Patrick droned on reading from the list from a sheet of paper because it was too long to memorise, I kept my eyes closed,
trying to think prayerfully,
but mostly imagining the day when my name would find its way onto that list, all the way at the end
when everyone had stopped listening.
When Patrick was finished, we said this stupid mantra together--living our best life today!--
and it was over. Augustus Waters pushed himself out of his chair and walked over to me.
His gait was crooked like his smile. He towered over me, but he kept his distance
so I wouldn't have to crane my neck to look him in the eye. "What's your name?" He asked. "Hazel."
"No, your full name?"
"um, Hazel Grace Lancaster."
He was just about to say something else when Isaac walked up.
"Hold on," Augustus said, raising a finger, and turned to Isaac.
"That was actually worse than you made it out to be."  "I told you it was bleak."  "Why do you bother with it?"
"I don't know. It kind of helps."
Augustus leaned in so he thought I couldn't hear. "She's a regular?"
I couldn't hear Isaac's comment, but Augustus responded, "I'll say!"
He clasped Isaac by both shoulders, and then took a half step away from him. "Tell hazel about clinic."
Isaac leaned a hand against the snack table and focused his huge eye on me.
"All right, so I went to clinic this morning
And I was telling my surgeon that I'd rather be deaf than blind and he said it doesn't work that way.
And I was like 'Yeah, I realize it doesn't work that way,
I'm just saying that I'd rather be deaf than blind if I had the choice, which I realize I don't have.'
and he said, 'Well, the good news is you won't be deaf.' And I was like "Yeah, hey,
Thanks for explaining that my eye cancer isn't going to make me deaf.
I feel so fortunate that an intellectual giant like yourself would deign to operate on me.'"  "He sounds like a winner,"
I said, "I'm try to give me some eye cancer just so I can make that guy's acquaintance."
"Good luck with that," Isaac said, "All right, I should go. Monica's waiting for me upstairs.
I gotta look at her a lot while I can."
"Counterinsurgence tomorrow?" Augustus asked.
"Definitely." Isaac turned and ran up the stairs, taking them two at a time.
Augustus Waters turned to me. "Literally," he said. "Literally?" I asked.
"We are literally in the heart of Jesus,"  he said, "I thought we were in a church basement, but we are literally in the heart of Jesus."
"Someone should tell Jesus," I said, "I mean it's got to be dangerous storing children with cancer in your heart."
"I would tell him myself," Augustus said, "but unfortunately
I am literally stuck inside of his heart, so he won't be able to hear me."
I laughed.
He shook his head. Just looking at me. "What?" I asked. "Nothing," he said. "Why are you looking at me like that?"
Augustus half smiled. "Because you're beautiful. I enjoy looking at beautiful people, and I decided a while ago
not to deny myself the simpler pleasures of existence."
A brief awkward silence ensued.
Augustus plowed through. "I mean particularly given that as you so deliciously pointed out all of this will end in oblivion and everything..."
I kind of scoffed or sighed or exhaled in a way that was meant to be vaguely cough-y, and then said, "I'm not a beaut--"
"You're like a millennial Natalie Portman, like a 'V for Vendetta' Natalie Portman."
"Never seen it," I said. "Really?" he asked, "Pixie haired gorgeous girl dislikes authority and can't help but fall for a boy
she knows his trouble. It's your autobiography as far as I can tell."
His every syllable flirted. Honestly, he kind of turned me on.
I didn't even know that guys could turn me on, not like in Real Life.
A younger girl walked past us. "How's it going, Elisa?" he asked. She smiled and mumbled "Hi, Augustus."
"Memorial people," he explained. Memorial was the big research hospital. "Where do you go?"
"Children's," I said my voice smaller than I expected it to be.
He nodded. The conversation seemed over. "Well..." I said,
nodding vaguely toward the steps that led us out of the literal heart of Jesus.
I tilted my card onto its wheels and started walking.
He limped beside me. "So see you next time, maybe?" I asked. "You should see it," He said, "V for Vendetta, I mean."
"Okay," I said, "I'll look it up." "No, with me, at my house, now," he said.
I stopped walking. "I hardly know you, Augustus Waters. You could be an ax murderer."
He nodded. "True enough, Hazel Grace."
He walked past me, his shoulders filling out his green knit polo shirt
His back straight, his steps lilting
Just slightly to the right as he walked steady and confident on what I had determined was a prosthetic leg.
Osteosarcoma sometimes takes a limb or two to check you out, and if it likes you, it takes the rest.
I followed him upstairs losing ground as I made my way up slowly, stairs not being a field of expertise for my lungs,
and then we were out of Jesus's heart,
and in the parking lot. The spring air, just on the cold side of perfect, the late afternoon light heavenly in its hurtfulness.
Mom wasn't there yet, which was unusual because mom was almost always waiting for me.
I glanced around and saw that a tall curvy brunette girl had Isaac pinned against the stone wall of the church,
kissing him rather aggressively. They were close enough to me that I could hear the weird noises of their mouths together
and I could hear him saying "Always," and her saying "Always," in return.
Suddenly standing next to me, Augustus half whispered, "They're big believers in PDA."
"What's with the always?" The slurping sounds intensified. "Oh, that's their thing.
They'll always love each other and whatever.
I would conservatively estimate that they have texted each other the word
"Always" four million times in the last year."
A couple more cars drove up, taking Michael and Elisa away.
It was just Augustus and me now,
watching Isaac and Monica, who proceeded apace as if they were not leaning against an actual place of worship.
His hand reached for her boob over her shirt and pawed at it, his palms still while his fingers moved around.
I wondered if that felt good. Didn't seem like it would but I decided to forgive Isaac on the grounds that he was going blind.
The senses must feast while there is yet hunger and whatever.
"Imagine taking that last drive to the hospital," I said, "The last time you'll ever drive a car."
Without looking over at me, Augustus said,
"You're killing my vibe here, Hazel Grace. I'm trying to observe young love and its many splendored awkwardnessess."
"I think he's hurting her boob," I said. "Yeah, it's difficult to ascertain whether he's trying to arouse her or perform a breast exam."
Then Augustus waters reached into a pocket and pulled out, of all things, a pack of cigarettes.
He flipped it open and put a cigarette between his lips.
"Are you serious?" I asked,
"You think that's cool? Oh my God, you just ruined the whole thing!"
"Which whole thing?" he asked, turning to me.
The cigarette dangled unlit from the unsmiling corner of his mouth.
"The whole thing where a boy who is not unattractive or
unintelligent or seemingly in any way
unacceptable stares at me and points out incorrect uses of literality and compares me to
actresses and asks me to watch a movie at his house, but of course there is always a hamartia.
And yours is that, oh my God, even though you had freaking cancer,
you give money to a company in exchange to a-- in exchange for the opportunity to acquire yet more cancer.
Oh my God! Let me just assure you that not being able to breathe sucks!
Totally disappointing. Totally."
"A hamartia?" he asked, the cigarette still in his mouth. It tightened his jaw.
He had a hell of a jawline, unfortunately. "A fatal flaw," I explained, turning away from him.
I stepped toward the curb, leaving Augustus Waters behind me, and then I heard a car start down the street. It was mom.
She'd been waiting for me to like, make friends or whatever. I felt this weird mix of
disappointment and anger welling up inside of me.
I don't even know what the feeling was really, just that there was a lot of it,
and I wanted to smack Augustus Waters and also replace my lungs with lungs that didn't suck at being lungs.
I was standing with my Chuck Taylors on the very edge of the curb,
the oxygen tank ball and chaining in the cart by my side and right as Mom pulled up, I felt a hand grab mine.
I yanked my hand free, but turned back to him.
"They don't kill you unless you light them," he said as Mom arrived at the curb, "And I've never lit one.
It's a metaphor. See, you put the killing thing right between your teeth, but you don't give it the power to do its killing."
"It's a metaphor," I said, dubious. Mom was just idling. "It's a metaphor," he said.
"You choose your behaviors based on their metaphorical resonances?" I said.
"Oh, yeah," he smiled, the big, goofy real smile.
"I'm a big believer in metaphor, Hazel Grace."
I turned to the car. Tapped on the window. It rolled down. "I'm going to a movie with Augustus Waters," I said.
"Please record the next several episodes of the ANTM Marathon for me."
That's the end of chapter one!
The Fault in Our Stars is really, it's the story of Hazel and Augustus and their attempt to come to terms with that
soliloquy that Hazel has at the beginning of the book there, about how all of this will inevitably end in oblivion.
And their life together and
And their families and stuff. That's what the book is, so I hope you guys enjoyed the first chapter,
and I hope that you like the the rest of the book as well if and when you have
the opportunity to read it. There are links in the doobly-doo
if you want to preorder a signed copy. All copies will be signed. Before I go, I will show you the TFIOS-ometer.
Let me tell you that I have made significant progress. I'm actually very nearly up to
135,000, I think, although I haven't done a count recently, so just about 20,000 to go, maybe even a little less than 20,000... yeah.
I think just about like
15,000 to go, but I'm not positive. I don't... I don't know. I should do a count. It's somewhere between 15 and 20
um
but uh
Thank you all so much for making it possible
for me to sign all of these books and spend the last three months of my life watching
television and listening to audiobooks and signing my name over and over again. It's been fun.
I'm really grateful to all of you, and I will read and respond to comments. This is good, this video is going to stay up.
It's going to be my vlogbrothers video for the day, for those of you who are late,
I'm not getting punished because I cleared this with Hank, so I know that
it's longer than four minutes, and it's not edited or anything like that,
but it is going to free up time so that I can sign these remaining books. Which is very very very very
valuable to me right now. Oh look, it's Maureen Johnson with her dirty dirty text messages.
hahahaha
That was actually a really good one of Maureen Johnson's better dirty jokes. Every time I do a live show,
even ones that are going to live into perpetuity, Maureen Johnson
sends me a dirty dirty text message of some kind with some kind of joke that I can never repeat because they are so
unfathomably filthy. um...
So anyway, I hope you guys like the fault in Our Stars. Again,
there are pre-order links below if you want to preorder a signed copy. Certainly don't feel obligated...
Um, but you know if you want to I'm happy to sign a book for you.
I'm going to sign them anyway.
So, um, I'm happy if they go to a nice nerdfighter nerdfightastic  home instead of going to, like, Target.
Nothing against Target! Oh God, now Target's going to be mad at me. I love you Target!
You're like my favorite of the two major Big-box stores. um...
So anyway, thank you guys so much,
and I'm gonna make a joke now that's going to make sense to very few of you,
But I'm doing it as a favor to the person who got me a paper jogger. A nerd fighter gave me a paper jogger.
Which is, Watch out for bears and
and I'm also going to say to all of you an inside joke that you will get.
French the llama for making my career possible, for the extraordinary
gift that you've given me by like watching this video into its 36th minute and
As always don't forget to be awesome and best wishes.